très honnêtement je pense que de ne pas
considérer qu'on arènes de saint
domingue serait dangereux la première
vague de la coved est presque passé déjà
on parle de l'arrivée d'une deuxième
vague mais est ce vraiment inévitable
prédire l'évolution d'une pandémie même
localement
cet expert c'est comme le site prédire
le temps qu'il fera au mois d'août on a
encore du trou dans nos connaissances
on connaît pas encore la réaction de la
population déconfinement essayer de
prédire qu'est ce qui va arriver
même dans les deux prochains on sait
quand même que depuis un siècle le monde
a connu huit pandémie qui ont duré plus
d'un an mais que seule la moitié de ces
virus respiratoires on provoque une
deuxième vague de contamination
l'arrivée d'une seconde vague dépend
également de la contagiosité d'un virus
et de sa résistance à la chaleur
estivale
mais le facteur humain joue aussi un
rôle de premier plan
plus il ya de grands rassemblements et
puis on s'expose à ce qu'on appelle un
événement de super propagation on le 24
juin tous fait appel on à la fête
nationale en même temps on a le
déménagement est à + sont à 7 jours
d'intervalle deux mois ce que je regarde
vraiment c'est qu'est ce qu'on va avoir
comme effet le disent dans la donne dans
le coin du 10 juillet comme deux
semaines en prison
dans le pire des scénarios la deuxième
vague des passerelles la première en
importance avant de s'aplatir sur longue
période
on peut pas l'écarter et devant le fait
qu'on peut pas l'écarter qu'on a pas de
vaccin ni de traitement spécifique
il faut se préparer pour ça et je crois
que l'on n'aura pas l'excusé de ne pas
être prêt mais un autre scénario
possible
après la première vague c'est une série
de petites vagues d éclosion qui frappe
en ville et en région ça va pas
nécessairement dire confirme le québec
au complet
mais ça se peut que ce soit
déconfinement locaux le temps d'étouffer
l'épidémie de reprendre le contrôle
local pour contrôler des éclosions
dispersif audrey des équipes médicales
volante en appui aux équipes locales
éventuellement si possible des
volontaires un corps civil entraîné à
répondre aux urgences de santé publique
c'est un sujet qui est sur la table je
crois que le gouvernement y réfléchit on
est déjà un modèle qui est en trinquet
déjà mis en place par rapport à la croix
rouge dans l'ouest de l'île de montréal
et ce serait un modèle semblable mais
fait à l'échelle de la province la
population respecte minimalement les
règles l'été devrait être au calme
pensent les experts
après on verra c'est des questions qu'on
a le temps de se poser aujourd'hui en
sachant qu'on a une une baisse de cas
donc là on a un moment pour souffler un
moment pour réfléchir il faut regarder
tous les scénarios
il faut se préparer pour le pire des
scénarios ici non magron d'un radio
canada montréal